PROFESSOR: The issue
of the approximate rate
at which things happen is a
common in a lot of sciences,
the rate at which
things fall, or the rate
at which reactions occur.
And in computer science, typical
concern about growth rates
comes up in looking at the
efficiency of algorithms,
and whether they're growing
linearly, or quadratically,
or more.
And we're going to look
today at four notations that
describe relations between
the growth rates of functions.
The first of these relations
is the simplest one.
It's called asymptotic
equivalence,
or asymptotic equality.
So this is tilde symbol is read
as asymptotically equal to.
So f of n is asymptotically
equal to g of n,
if and only if the limit of the
quotient of f of n over g of n
is 1.
Let's look at an example.
N squared is asymptotically
equal to n squared plus n.
Why is that?
Well, it follows trivially
by manipulating the algebra.
The limit of n squared
plus n over n squared,
simplifying, is just the same
as the limit of 1 plus 1 over n.
But as n goes to
infinity, 1 over n
goes to 0, so the
limit is 1 as claimed.
Those two expressions, or
the functions they define,
n squared and n squared plus
1 are asymptotically equal.
So there's some easy properties
of asymptotic equality
that follow immediately
from the definition.
One of them is that
it's symmetric,
namely, suppose that f is
asymptotically equal to g.
I want to prove that g is
asymptotically equal to f.
Well, what's going on here?
Let's look at the limit
of g over f, which
is what I'd like to prove as 1.
Well, the limit of g over
f, by algebra, g over f
is the same as 1 over f over
g, so just moving a limit
across the division,
that's the same as 1
over the limit of f over
g, which is 1 over 1.
And we've proved in
other words, the g
is asymptotically equal to f,
given that f is asymptotically
equal to g.
It's symmetric.
There's a similar
argument for transitivity.
Let's just crank through it
for practice on the definition.
Suppose that f is
asymptotically equal to g,
and g is asymptotically
equal to h,
I'd like to prove that f it's
asymptotically equal to h.
Well, again, we just
plug into the algebra
and distribute limits.
Let's just look at this.
We're given that 1 is
the limit of f over g,
because f is asymptotic to g.
But f over g can be expressed
as f over h divided by g over h.
That's just algebra.
The h's cancel.
So this limit, now, I
can distribute the limits
to the numerator
and denominator,
assuming both exist,
and the numerator limit
is what I'm interested in.
The denominator limit
is going to be 1,
because the limit
of g over h is 1.
Since g is asymptotically
equal to h,
the conclusion is indeed
that the limit of f over h
is equal to 1.
This is not really
very interesting stuff,
and the top level
message is that
many of these
elementary properties
of asymptotic equality and
the other asymptotic relations
that we're going to
see follow by this kind
of elementary algebra, and
distributing the limits
over sub expressions.
Anyway, the corollary of this
is that asymptotic equality
is in fact an
equivalence relation.
We've proved it's
symmetric and transitive,
and it's trivially reflexive.
It's an equivalence relation.
By the way, it's
worth noting that it's
an equivalence relation on
functions of one variable, when
we write sometimes that
f of n is asymptotically
equal to g of n.
But we mean that f of n is the
description of the function f.
We're not talking about
the number that f of n
happens to have for some
particular value of f.
So we'll sometimes
write f of n is
asymptotically equal to g of n.
For descriptive purposes,
the proper thing
we should be writing is that f
is asymptotically equal to g.
Asymptotic equality is a
relation between functions.
OK.
The next asymptotic relation
we're going to look at
is called asymptotically smaller
than, and the notation for it
is this little o notation.
So you'd write that f of n is
equal to little o of g of n,
if and only if the limit of f
of n over g of n goes to 0 as n'
approaches infinity.
So let's look at
an example of that.
N squared is little
o of n cubed,
because trivially, the limit
of n squared over n cubed
is the same as the
limit of 1 over n.
It's equal to zero.
And by similar kind
of reasoning that we
did for asymptotic equality
being an equivalence relation,
it's not very hard to
prove that little o defines
a strict partial
order on functions.
So the third asymptotic
relation is the most complicated
of the three.
It's arguably the most
important in computer science.
It's called the asymptotic
order of growth, o.
And the definition
is that if function
f is big o of a function
g, what it means
is that the limit of
f over g is finite.
So it might be other than
0 or 1, but it's finite.
And that means that
f is big o of g.
Now, there's a
technicality there
where the expression actually
says the limsup of f of n
over g of n.
Let's just ignore that for
now, and we'll look at it
and explain why the limsup
is there a little later.
So as an example,
3n squared is big o
of n squared, because
the quotient of 3n
squared over n squared is 3,
which is less than infinity.
So what big o is doing is kind
of saying that constant factors
don't matter.
And that turns out to be
particularly useful in computer
science, where you can't
really talk about the time
that a procedure takes,
because that's going
to depend on the hardware.
So when you implement
it on faster hardware,
it may grow at the
same rate, but the time
will actually change.
And that's why big o
plays a prominent role.
The final relation
of the four is called
theta, or same order of growth.
The definition of
f is theta of g
is simply that f is o
of g and g is o of f.
And it's easy to show
from the definition
that theta is an
equivalence relation.
So to summarize, there
are these four relations.
F asymptotically equal
to g means informally
that f and g are nearly equal.
F equals little o of
g informally means
that f is much less than g.
F equals o of g means
that f is roughly less
than or equal to
g, where roughly
means that we're not concerned
about constant factors.
And f equals theta of g means
that f is roughly equal to g.
And we'll examine
these properties
in more detail in
the next segment.